ugh
what is it about a really good meal
it's a chance to quiet that inner
monologue
and to enjoy the sounds
textures and obviously
tastes oh damn
you guys are making me hungry
let's face it it's a big world out there
with all kinds of amazing foods
if you only had someone to give you a
tour
oh yeah you do you have me
join me on a quest to find the most
delicious
destinations on earth
[Music]
from the best late night eats in the
concrete jungle we got a lot of good
characters over here
don't miss hidden gems in the actual
jungle
nice costa rican restaurant costa rican
ingredients it just blows my mind
the ultimate guide to the top local
spots
serious dining and parking lots tourists
wants to come here and
eat and drink where locals and
all that salt city sauce sauce
oh man having a quasi-religious
experience
ugh i'm gonna cuddle up with that and go
night night
if food is your higher calling come take
a journey we receive every outsider with
open arms it's paradise
and get ready to feed your soul this is
off the chain
ah did we forget our drinks
when the butcher kisses the meat you
know it's good
[Music]
really
[Music]
you